We are now ready to define
profile Hidden Markov Models for
classifying proteins into families,
a difficult task in bioinformatics.
Classifying proteins into families is
important because, as soon as a protein is
classified as a family member,
we know the function of this protein.
However, the similarities may be
subtle for diverse proteins, and
therefore, pairwise
similarities may fail to detect
what family a given newly
sequenced protein belongs to.
However, the protein may have weak
similarities with as many
proteins in the family, and it will help
us to assign this protein to a family.
But we need new computational techniques
for finding such subtle similarities.
Let's start from the alignment of some number
of proteins, as shown on this slide,
and let's remove columns if the fraction
of insertions exceeds the threshold "theta",
the maximum fraction
of insertions per column.
And after we've done this, we'll
construct an alignment where each
column has a relatively small
number of insertions.
We can further construct the
profile of this alignment.
And finally, we will construct an HMM
corresponding to this profile.
This is actually a strange HMM
because the probability of transition
from every state to the next state,
next to the right state is one.
Therefore, there is nothing
probabilistic about this HMM with
respect to the transition probability matrix.
However, with respect to emission
probabilities, there is a probabilistic
meaning of this HMM, and it corresponds to every
new protein having certain probabilities
of being emitted by this HMM.
But this HMM has a major flaw: it is not
clear how to model insertions in this HMM.
For example, how would we represent this
protein in the framework of this HMM?
Well, an obvious way is to add
insertion states, like this one,
And if there are multiple insertions,
we will also connect the
insertion state with itself.
And finally,
we will design the HMM with
these insertion states.
Now, we took care of insertions,
and this would be the path in
the HMM corresponding to this protein.
But what about deletions?
And there is a simple way to account for
deletions,
let's say for this deletion,
by introducing transitions between
all states to the right in this
HMM diagram, like this state.
However, the question arises,
how many such edges
in the HMM diagram will we have after
adding all these possible transitions?
In this case, we added only transitions
for a given node of the HMM diagram,
and there are already many edges.
And as you remember, the running time of the
Viterbi algorithm equals the number of edges,
or in the HMM diagram, multiplied by
the number of emitted symbols.
So, solving the corresponding decoding
problem will be time consuming.
However, there is a better way.
We can introduce deletion
states in the HMM diagram.
And in this case,
we can route the sequence through these
newly-introduced deletion states.
We need to introduce all of them,
of course,
and that's now how the deletion
issue will be addressed: with
introducing a relatively small number
of new edges in the HMM diagram.
So here's the path corresponding to this
protein that is shown at
the bottom of this diagram.
And I want to ask you a question:
Are there any edges missing
in this HMM diagram?
And of course, there are missing edges
between deletion and insertion states.
We will add them, and
our HMM diagram is almost done.
The only thing we need to add
is the start and end states.
However, the question that
remains unanswered is:
What are the transition and
emission probabilities for this HMM?
And we wanted to define
the profile HMM Problem,
which is to construct a profile
HMM from a multiple alignment.
The input to this problem is a multiple
alignment and a threshold "theta",
the maximum fraction of
insertions per column, and
the output: transition and
emission matrices of the profile HMM.
Let's construct hidden paths for
every row of the multiple
alignment in the profile HMM.
Please note that we are
constructing hidden paths
in the HMM diagram, not in
the Viterbi graph of the HMM.
We haven't even constructed
the Viterbi graph yet.
So for the top row
in the multiple alignment,
this will be our green path
through the HMM diagram.
This is the red path,
corresponding to the second row.
And this is yet another path,
corresponding to the third row.
And here all five paths correspond
to each row of the multiply alignment,
and the question arises: How do we
compute transition probabilities
based on these paths?
Let's take a look at one particular
node in this HMM diagram and in these paths.
Only four out of five paths
pass through this node,
and there are therefore four
transitions from this state, M5.
Three of them go to the state I5, one goes
to the state M6, and zero go the state D6.
And therefore, it makes sense to
define transition probabilities from
M5 to I5 as three over four,
transition probability from M5
to M6 as one over four, and
transition probability from
M5 to D6 as zero.
It turns out that this common sense
assigning of transition probabilities
actually corresponds to optimal assigning of
transition probabilities in the HMM diagram.
But what about the emission probabilities?
In this case, we'll look at the node M2,
and it is traversed,
again, by four out of five paths,
and the emitted symbols are C,
F, C, and D from this state.
And therefore, we define the emission
probabilities correspondingly
according to the count of
the emitted symbols from this state.
We are almost done with
defining the profile HMM for
multiple alignment, but
let's consider a small complication
caused by forbidden transitions
in the HMM diagram.
Please note that most transitions
between states in the profile
HMM are forbidden, and
the graph of the HMM diagram shown here
only shows the allowed transitions.
So, the transition matrix,
matrix of transition probabilities, for
this HMM diagram, is mainly empty.
We shown gray cells here corresponding
to allowed transitions, and
clear cells corresponding
to forbidden transitions.
Everything is zero in
the forbidden transitions.
But please note that there are also
many zeroes in the gray cells,
and you should worry about
these zeros because they simply
indicate that the number of rows in
our multiply alignment is small.
And therefore,
don't forget about pseudocounts.
In this HMM, by adding
small pseudocounts for
every gray cell in the matrix of
transition probabilities for the profile HMM,
as we've usually done in the section when
we considered finding motifs in DNA.